the historic Midwest floods are getting
worse a week after that disaster started
to unfold a new levee breach yesterday
on the Missouri River forced the
evacuation of the entire town of Craig
Missouri in just hours
officials now estimate the cost of the
flooding in four states to be in the
billions of dollars in Iowa
the governor said she is going to ask
President Trump to quickly announce a
disaster declaration to help with
recovery efforts Don Dahler is in
flooded Hamburg Iowa which is several
miles from the Missouri River Don what's
it look like this morning yeah good
morning well as you can see it's wet
this is actually Main Street the water
gets a lot deeper the further you go in
that direction but of course it's never
a good idea to go wandering around
flooded streets and I have to tell you
it is really eerie seeing those street
lights stretch all the way into the
distance as we take an overhead look
I'll tell you this much of this is from
the Missouri River which came rushing in
here when suddenly hundreds of miles of
levees were breached and within a matter
of minutes Hamburg became a town
submerged in Hamburg Iowa nothing was
spared the homes and businesses of the
nearly 1,200 people who live here were
totally submerged there's no place for
the water to go Major General Scott
Spellman and his team from the Army
Corps of Engineers assessed the
devastation from above you signed up to
protect people to help people so how
does this affect you personally to see
this town under water you're dealing
with
people and communities that are having
really the worst day of their lives and
we understand the frustration we want to
do everything we can within our
authorities as fast as we can to help
them as we rode through Main Street it
was only passable by boat Hamburg built
a secondary levee before a major flood
in 2011 it kept this area dry problem is
the Army Corps of Engineers asked them
to lower it to 5 feet high to meet
federal regulations and this flood was
nine feet it just rolled in Kathy crane
has been the town's mayor for 12 years
this is a tough community there were
little and we're not wealthy
we're not well how are you gonna rebound
from this we're asking for help we want
to keep our businesses here want to keep
our homes we want to keep our citizens
there are people there we've known all
our lives we have noticed the water has
been slowly receding I wouldn't be able
to be standing here two days ago but the
residents are really concerned that with
those levees basically destroyed the
town might be susceptible to even more
flooding in the coming months fionna
there are so many people that are
suffering right now and where you're
standing on Main Street really looks
like a lake it really puts things into
perspective thank you